the Joe Rogan experience because he's in
Rikers and Rikers has a massive outbreak
no yes yeah he's in Rikers he's in
maximum security he's in Buffalo now oh
well do they move into that because of
the corona he's in a hospital Buffalo
he's fired
he's he probably has no will to
live you know I mean he probably doesn't
have a will to get through this I mean I
don't know what kind of medical
treatment they're gonna give him but
this could do him in easily it's running
rampant he's so sick already you look at
the guy he can barely walk his health is
deteriorating all that the stress from
this drought killed him crushed him took
20 years off his life instantly this is
just a death sentence why don't you I
was just saying we were talking about
this yesterday imagine if you came up to
him four years ago and said I want to
show you your future dying in a bed in
prison for things you've already done
right now you're walking around toast of
the town getting in limos climbing out
people are waving to you and cheering
you're getting interviewed on the carpet
everyone shouts you out I just want to
thank Harvey Weinstein for his amazing
amazing company and the boovies you put
together that allowed me to shine yeah
how many people have you seen all the
people that that praised him and then
four years later imagine that he think
the things he's already done he'd
already done them at that point and they
knew why they were brazen I wonder if
what they knew they knew they knew
scumbag they know yeah you got to assume
they all know so what the yeah
they went back they knocked on doors
wait a second so I rape you you don't go
to that party what do you mean
so I raped you I had a party now the
next year there's going to be another
can festival and you're going to show up
again because they wanted to work see
the thing about Harvey is apparently
this is Whitney Cummings take on it she
said he would actually give them the
things he would tell them he would give
them so he'd say hey you sucked my dick
I'm gonna make you a star and he would
actually do it he would actually put
them in these movies he would give them
what this so they were happy so they
would get all this treatment and they
have a spend some alone time with him
every now
so they would send him emails
lovey-dovey emails but really they hated
him and that's when all this came out he
didn't even see it comment cuz he
thought that they loved him he thought
that they would send him these emails so
he sent the emails to the press like
look look at all these emails these
girls love me even though he had done
scumbag to them it's just he had it
set up where this was how you got by
this is how you made movies this is how
you want to be famous this is how you
get famous I can help you get famous you
got to help me get rid of some come who
think this day everyone
I think everyone did all the guys do
really every guy threatened him because
he will feel real intractable apparently
oh I don't know man one of the people
said the producer did not have symptoms
and was under close observation was not
clear why he had been tested on you
there's a lot of that don't sound
right to me
they don't give listen in vick's are the
last people they care about
[Applause]